Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn. It's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
January 13th,
2014 are you doing Monday the
13th you know, I heard that one's,
it's bad luck to oh with
the a fucking trinkets.
Oh,
what are you going to grow up and just
just fucking man up lady and realize that
you fucked up your own life.
You know,
you know those people that got to spin
around three times and throw some cookie
crumbs over there.
Fucking padded shoulder.
You know, so, so, so something
doesn't, something bad doesn't happen.
I'd like to take all superstitious people,
put them in a room and after I'm done
slapping him with a fucking garden hose,
I just like to tell them that listen,
bad shit happens in life. Okay?
No matter what you got
hanging around your neck now,
I mean how many times you
fucking point your fucking toe,
your left boy due south.
Whatever the fuck you supposed to do,
it's still going to happen.
Still gonna happen.
Balances out the good shit. All
right, so why don't you stop,
meet such a fucking pussy. Oh Man am
I talked about that a long time ago.
I don't care if you do it. You don't. I'm
going to bring it back up. Do you ever,
did you guys ever see that there was
a Jesus camp? No. No, no, no, no.
It was one of those big brothers shows,
one of those shows, one of those,
one of those. What else?
Fucking reality shows.
You know where they got a couple of
meatheads in there? One of them's gay,
the other has no was raised by wolves.
And then there's a couple of hotties,
there's never a fat chick.
You know all these people getting
in trouble for fat shaming.
How about these reality shows once
the last time you saw a fat chick just
walking around in a thong
in the big brother house,
you're never going to see it.
You're never going to fucking see it.
All right.
The only time they put them on fat
people on a reality show, if it is,
if the show is about,
I don't want to be fat anymore,
you know,
I can't think of one.
But anyways,
there was this show and
there was some chick on it,
the reality show and every time she
had some big challenge coming up,
she had to climb into a
fucking tree house, you know,
without tipping over the cupcakes.
Whatever the fuck they're supposed
to do is some angry at his dad hosts.
Now the blue team slowing down.
What the fuck?
You know that guy from the island show?
What is it called?
Dangerous as survivor.
I fucking hate that show with my wife
watches that Goddamn show and we both sit
there laughing. He's such a
cunt. I Dunno what happened.
He never used to be that way. I think
he's sick of doing it. One of those like,
be careful what you wish for.
Like,
I mean at first it was his dream job.
He comes home to his wife, honey,
I got this idea for a show. I'm so fucking
sick of being out here in Hollywood.
Stuck in this God damn traffic.
You know,
trying to get the that side of the four
oh five Todd addition to be fifth banana
and like a fucking chaps to commercial.
I don't want to do it anymore. Okay.
I'm thinking of,
uh,
moving to Colorado Springs and
opening up a fucking burrito joint.
What do you think? And she's sitting
there going, wow, why don't, okay,
I understand you're stressed.
Um,
so go ahead. Just say it for me
anyways. That's not what I'm saying.
I'm saying just, just, you know, you're
very emotional at this point. These,
this is very, this is extreme. Um,
why don't you create your own show?
You know,
why don't you just, I
dunno. You like Iowa,
don't you? We will. You
do like go. All right.
And then they just sit there at the
little fucking starving artists kitchen
table and they come up with this fucking
show that puts him on a god Damn Island.
He gets paid, he's on TV.
He's going to get, you know,
groupie island, chest hair, pussy, right.
Chest air mean chicks who like tanned
up chests with, with, with hair on it.
And he gets his job.
Okay.
But then they're like, well wait, wait,
no, no. Before that they're like, well,
I don't, I don't know how to
write a script and like, well,
why don't we just make it like a
game show? Well that fucking stupid,
right? And he's all pissed again and
he wants to go back to the Burrito.
But she kept them in the pocket.
Like every great woman behind every
great man kept him in the pocket.
And some are at some point,
probably halfway through the second joint,
they fucking realize, wait a
minute, what about the real world?
We'll do a reality show,
right?
We'll take 10 fucking morons and
we'll stick them on this. God Damn,
I would all right. And they'll, they'll,
they'll play hopscotch and fucking
connect for whatever the fuck we got to do
and the last fucking so whatever.
So he gets the God damn job.
I didn't know what the
fuck I am in this anymore.
So he gets a fucking job and now this,
he's out there and did this.
This is a tipping point
where after a while it just,
you're a human being and
you just get fucking bored
of the same fucking routines. The exact
way that I ended up in this business, I,
one of the main reasons maybe why I
travel so much is because one of the most
depressing feelings I ever had when I,
back when I was in the Matrix and I
actually had a real fucking job, you know,
I got up in the morning and made
myself a little tuna fish sandwich.
A little plastic thing is some fritos
toss an apple in there walking out to the
car,
right?
The grease from the Fritos already
making that pit stain on my little brown
is I walk up to my rusted out car hoping
it's going to start hope and I don't
have a problem with the fucking old,
okay.
Right.
There was nothing more fucking depressing.
Then that moment when I was,
had been there for a year and I was
actually sitting there going one year ago,
I was right fucking here.
I hated that shit.
And I think that that fucking island dude,
he's not an island dude.
He's a mainland dude
on the fucking island.
I think it's fucking with
them at this point. Okay.
He doesn't give a shit anymore.
He just wants to get through those
stupid fucking obstacle courses cause he
wants to get, he's going fucking
nuts out there. He's already,
these guys have been out on that fucking
island since like 1999. All right.
At this point,
he's kind of like those Japanese soldiers
that didn't know World War Two ended
and they didn't find him until 1974.
That's what the fuck is
going on with this guy.
So I don't know if you've noticed,
but Nia watches that show religiously
and with every season that fucking guy
gets angrier and angrier.
Now the red team,
they need to pick it
up. You just shit. Fuck.
I just realized she's still sleeping
upstairs. Uh, what the fuck?
It's five at 10 in the morning.
You know,
at that point I'm allowed to
fucking drill a jackhammer.
I get to a fucking podcast.
This is how I win arguments.
I rehearse what I'm going to
say before I get into, you know,
and then during the argument
I act like I'm fishing.
Like I don't already have the
information and that's how I win. Um,
anyways, this is the Monday
morning podcast everybody and uh,
yeah,
I don't even know what
the fuck I was talking.
I was talking about a
superstitious people. Boop, boop,
boop,
boop.
You guys like when I do Stevie wonder,
could that have been any wider bup, bup,
beat up booboo.
You know what?
I think I'm going to do that
down in Korea town tonight.
I'll probably get a standing ovation.
Um, golden globes. Everybody.
Look, I went from reality
TV. What was I talking?
I was talking about fat chicks and thongs
does that my point.
Oh, there's never any point to
this fucking thing. The point is,
is for me to talk for an hour and just
somehow eat up an hour your Monday.
That's what it is. Whether it's in
the morning or it's in the afternoon.
One of my favorite things about this
podcast is that it is called the Monday
morning podcast in the amount of fucking
people who so selfishly feel that it's
their Monday.
You know,
like they're doing any sort of heavy
lifting on this podcast other than
downloading it for fucking free.
All right,
why don't you and your index
finger go fuck yourselves.
This is my Monday morning.
It's 9:56 AM where I am and I am
recording this fucking podcast.
All right.
How many times have you sent something
Fedex second day to get there before nine
and it doesn't get there till three,
three in the afternoon.
Are you one of those constant
to hold FedEx? You know,
try to get $3 in a quarter taken
off your little fucking envelope.
Not even thinking that you sent something
from San Diego to Bangor, Maine,
and isn't that fucking amazing?
Because me as a person who actually
gives a shit about getting there,
can't get there that quick.
Can I? I don't think I can.
I don't fucking know. It's amazing
because the letter doesn't care.
Doesn't have a dog in the fight.
It's fucking left.
It's just sitting there waiting to
biodegrade. So I cut him some slack.
Jesus Christ. Can you tell I
got a bunch of shit to do today.
None of this is gonna make sense. Um,
let's talk about the Golden Globes.
So, uh, oh, yesterday, yesterday
I went and I saw the, uh,
the other, the Wah Wah. So the
wolf, the wolf of Wall Street,
I saw with Joey roses in my lovely wife,
Nia.
I went down and I saw, I saw the
movie, we were in the movie theater.
We watched it together. It was, it was a
great moment because me and fucking, uh,
Derosa loves Scorsese.
All of his movies.
We quote him all the fucking
time verse he does it to yet,
I've never gone to a brand
news Scorsese scores,
Scorsese, however the fuck you
say it, they'll say it different.
Last night at the Golden Globes add,
didn't have an angry look on his face.
So I think I've been saying it
wrong. Of course. Score Sassy. Um,
we went down and saw his, uh, so I
was movie had a great fucking time.
Um,
okay.
And then I went home and I said,
all right, I'm going to fucking, uh,
yeah.
Oh, what moves my point? My point
was, oh, yeah, me, me and Joe,
we're going to start doing the
uninformed show again. All right.
We're in the same city. We're going
to start it out doing it once a month.
Okay.
And for those of you never heard
of it, it's basically UNEF, uh,
the uninformed show, no reading,
no research, just strong opinions.
And basically me and Joe, we go off
for an hour on a particular topic,
just coming from the hat,
making all kinds of ignorant statements.
And then when our, our
of ignorance is, is over,
we bring in an expert on whatever
topic we were discussing.
And then he basically tells us how
fucking stupid and wrong we are.
Then that's the shelf. All right?
But if he can't do the math on that,
I can't help you. Um, so we will
get an excited talking about that.
And, uh, so then later on last night
later, I decided I was going to,
while I don't know,
I'm going to be a good fucking person
here and I'm going to watch the Golden
Globes, right? I,
I watched the first playoff game and then
I recorded the second one playoffs and
a, so I watched the, I watched
the charges versus the Broncos.
I watched that game and about 50 minutes,
it was fucking phenomenal,
was fucking phenomenal.
And I already forget the name of the
charges receiver who just fucking,
it's going to be a God damn superstar.
Whatever the fuck his was. He really,
really impressed me on
the, uh, on the big stage,
on the big stage there. So, uh, oh
fuck it. Let's talk NFL football.
I'm already into it. What do you like,
how, what do you say? What do you say?
A football,
feds.
All the favorites one
as far as I can tell,
you know,
like verse, he said the dumbest
thing ever. He goes, patriots,
Broncos in the AFC
championship. Dude, I called it
oversee going out on a limb again.
Um,
I'll take Brady and manning.
I think they're going to do something,
but I actually, I didn't believe
in the Patriots. I still camp.
I can't believe how fucking
well they're playing.
The only injuries that
they've had obviously going
into Denver is going to be a
tough, a tough game. I traveled so
much. I think we beat them this year.
Yeah, we did. That's right.
They were up big and then we
came back and be all right.
It's not going to go in their
house and they're going to beat us.
That's how it works.
And the one I can't understand is,
uh,
this is going to be a tough one.
Seattle and San Francisco.
Cause you got the division rivals,
you never know which way it's going
to fucking go. It's like the Patriots,
no matter how good they are, every year
they're going to lose to the bills,
the jets and the dolphins.
Two out of three of them,
they're going to lose to him like once
at least,
unless they get some
juggernaut of a fucking thing.
But I'm just saying they see you twice.
They know what you do.
And every other fucking cliche out there,
but I still am sticking with Seattle,
uh,
blocking out that fucking Douche chill
12th man musical that's going on.
Oh, we registered in earthquake
every fucking game. Ah,
they'd go in the way the rate of France
to more and more people are starting to
become characters.
They're starting to paint their faces.
It's just somebody the real,
you know,
they have the real housewives
of fucking Atlanta.
I need the real Seattle
Seahawks fans of Seattle.
You got to tell those people to
leave the capes at home. You know,
every team has got that one jackass
that paints his fucking face,
shaves his head and sticks the
emblem on the side of his head.
Everybody's got that one
fucking jerk off and it's fine.
It's fine to have one,
but there is a tipping point in the
stance where there's too many of them
and they start bringing this size.
We would make it fun of that Shit.
Like if you have end zone seats
and you make a bullseye sign,
just how fucking on originally you are.
That's right up there with the defense
side and the John Three 16 I don't even
read the Bible. Okay. I don't
know how to make songs like that.
I don't know what words to use.
Sorry. Um, yeah. How about
an original fucking sign?
Yeah.
You run of the mill everyday.
Fucking conch sitting around talking
about all this comics. Not original.
That movie's not original.
This is derivative.
This guy ripped off this and look at you.
Look what you guys,
he got all fucking week.
Probably more than a week.
You probably got the tickets
for your birthday Assam. Shit.
You have all that time to come up with
a fucking side and you make the defense
side.
Why don't you just put on a stupid hat
and then act like you're the crazy guy,
despite the fact that you're a faithful
married father of three who pays his
taxes on time? Little toy you just saw.
Map happens when he puts out hat on.
We don't know what he's gonna do. He's
paid for his pretzels just like you are.
Ah, there's nothing I hate
more than the character.
Fucking the fan.
That's become a fucking character.
Ah, right there. I swear to God,
you know what they should do
to everybody who does that?
They should pull him out of the stands
and make them throw a ball in public.
Okay, and when you watched the,
the, the lack of whipping motion,
you don't let fall off a check throws
a ball that didn't have brothers.
You know what I mean?
The way they throw the,
our motion of a girl throwing,
who didn't have a dad that stuck around
and taught her how to throw a ball,
it literally looks like cheap animation.
Like it skipped a couple of frames.
It's just the worst thing. I would put
my money down, put your money down.
I'd put my money down that if you took
one of those fucking face painted Douche
bags out of the fucking crowd,
that's how they would throw a ball.
I could be wrong.
I don't, I, I liked the way it used to be.
When you go to a fucking game back
in the day you went to the game,
maybe you had some old shitty
hat from your team. You know,
and that was it. And the rest you had you
stupid Jack. He just, the rest of you,
you know,
other than your fucking hat,
when you walked out of that stadium
and your alcohol level, you could do,
you could go to work. You just fucking
looked regular and you went there,
you drank beers,
you got drunk and you're scared kids.
That's what you did in the old
days. Okay. You have pissed Piston,
a giant horse trough and there wasn't any
Sushi and there wasn't in this fucking
dumb ass music.
What did I went to a game recently?
I went to the Bruins are
La Kings game and uh,
the Bruins played like, they really
enjoyed their time out here in la.
Do you have any times I've
gotten burned on that.
Any Boston fans who are coming
out here, um, and you know,
you get home sick and everything.
So anytime the Celtics,
the Bruins are the red sox,
go down to fucking Anaheim,
play the angels or whatever,
unless they do some inner league shit
with the Dodgers, you're gonna to go. Um,
I got to warn you actually
specifically with the, uh,
with, with the Bruins and the
Celtics. I gotta warn you. Okay.
Don't buy expensive tickets
cause I'm telling you,
especially with hockey,
and these poor bastards have to go play.
Uh,
they got to go do a road trip
in the middle of February,
two cow, Winnipeg, Calgary, Edmonton,
and Vancouver. It, that's fucking kill me.
I would be a raging alcoholic
if I had to do that.
So by the time they come down
to the sunny fucking cities, I,
they got cabin fever. I'm telling
you. Or it's just, you know,
La has got some of the best look
at women out here. They're famous.
I'm telling you, if they don't
play, I can't believe the kings.
Yeah,
it took them this long to get good.
I would think that they would fucking
destroy all east coast teams and Canadian
teams other than maybe Vancouver just
because they don't fucking like each
other.
I don't know.
The amount of times I spent like 80 a
hundred bucks through stubhub to watch the
Celtics play the clippers back
when the clippers sucked. Um,
and I would watch the big three
come in there and just get smoked
fucking brutal. So I'm
just saying, all right,
just be careful with your money out here.
Just get the upper deck shit,
don't wear any this stuff.
Yeah.
It just go there dressed like you,
you fucking going to work or something
and then just cheer your team and it's
great if your team Wednesday win, if they
lose, you'll walk out of the stadium,
you know?
And you don't have to listen to anybody.
Take it to that next level that makes you
want to throw a fucking punch and then
you're going to get stomped
by the neck tattoo guy.
It's just a different thing out here.
It's not fun.
It's not a fun place to see a game
out here. They take it to a Ya,
that's just a different level.
You don't really like when you sit
around giving each other shit that'll get
sure that blah blah blah.
You shirts too tight and all that crap.
And there's somebody that yeah,
at least my mother was a dead.
There's always like that person.
That's what west coast fans are.
Okay.
Anyways, the fuck was I talking
about? Um, oh, NFL football.
So I still think it's a,
it is Seattle's.
I just think that, that, I dunno,
I just liked the way they play. They
get Marshawn lynch. He's a fucking,
it was the last time he didn't get
hit three times before he went down.
I
cannot get that fucking guy down.
All right. The defenses is insane. Keith
tell I've been on the road for so long,
I can't even fucking name anybody's
name. They have beautiful uniforms. No,
I just think out of the way they're
playing and I, I don't think that, uh,
I think they match up well with
the Broncos. I Dunno about the 49.
This is the Superbowl they get
by the 49 is, I'm, I'm, I'm,
I'm saying that went in it,
they beat the 40 niners they're
gonna win it because, uh,
okay.
I just did. Defense is better
than the Broncos and I think the,
with Marshawn Lynch,
they can fucking shoe up the clock and
if patient doesn't have the ball in his
hand,
what the fuck is he going to do?
And I think Peyton gets frustrated when
he goes up against really a physical
aggressive receivers.
At least he did back in the day when
that's what we had on our team. Um,
and who knows if the
Patriots go that Jesus,
I'll just be fucking thrilled
that we made it. I really will be.
And everybody's giving me Shit, dude. Oh,
can we come down in your own fucking team?
I don't know,
cause we lost their whole
fucking receiving core.
Okay.
Lost all these guys on defense.
I'm,
I'm stunned that they've been able
to do it once again. I'm saying it,
I'm telling you right now,
Tom Brady's have one of the best fucking
seasons he's ever had working with what
he's working with. All right. With that,
I have no idea it was going to one next
week. I hope we fucking win. But uh,
you know, I feel like, you
know, we beat them last time.
Okay.
And uh, I dunno, I was really
impressed with Denver's defense too.
So who the fuck knows whatever.
All I know is there going to be great
fucking games and I'm watching every
second of it. All right,
and that's the deal.
That's all they got to say about that.
All right,
let's do a little bit of
advertising here this week.
Little bit of folk and air visitation.
Uh Oh Gigi age. Where am
I? All right. All right.
Dollar Shave club, everybody. Guess
what? For a couple of bucks a month,
dollar shave club.com delivers amazing
quality razors right to your door.
Not only does it save you a ton of cash,
it saves you from tragedy to the drug.
Store it for a pack of blades.
All right?
Cause with dollar shave club
for a couple of bucks a month,
amazing quality raises that are delivered
right to your door. That's right.
No more wasted time and no more getting
hit up for 20 bucks every time you buy
razors.
No more getting caught behind the junkie
who finally decided to buy toothpaste
down at the frigging cvs.
No more of that.
The old people want to develop their
film and get an ice cream. Right.
And there's only one person working there,
which is a rule.
Now at every drug store,
there's only one person.
There's only one registered open.
There's one person on the floor and
they're hiding down near the alcohol.
You don't want to deal with that and get
screwed on the price. What do you do?
Go to dollar shave club. Everybody hears
getting their dollar shave club blades.
And you should too.
And here's another genius idea.
Try replacing your old shaving
cream with doctor cabbies. Evie
from Dollar Shave club.com trust me,
your face will thank you later.
Don't waste time with the drug store
behind the lady paying and Penny's.
Go to dollar shave club.com forward slash
burr or go to [inaudible] dot com and
click on the dollar shave club Banger.
Keep your stress level low.
When Your Bank Account Balance
High Shave time, shave money,
go to dollar shave club.com
forward slash burr they, you'd go,
oh. And in the bottom it says, note,
please personalize areas
highlighted in yellow.
Well all I have is black and white here.
So I feel like I did the right thing. Uh,
legal zoom, legal, zoom.
Some things like starting a business
or protecting your family with the will
aren't like your other new
year's resolutions. You can't
afford to blow them off.
Instead of less snacking
and more exercise, put them
at the top of your list.
Legal Zoom.
That sentence does not make sense.
Instead of less snacking
and more exercise, put them
at the top of your list.
Put what at the top of my list.
It's got to be legal zoom, right?
They wrote the copy.
Let's plow ahead.
Legal Zoom helps you
incorporate or form an LLC with.
There's simple questionnaire starting
at just $99 this is for all you dreamers
in your cubicles that you want to start
your business and protect yourself.
This is it.
You can do it for 99 bucks.
Over 1 million entrepreneurs
have done it in 90% of customers.
Recommend legal zoom
to friends and family.
You could also create a will starting
at just 69 bucks or even a living trust
quickly and easily and get peace of mind
and protection for only $69 you can't
beat it. No surprise fees,
no hassles, no headaches.
Legal Zoom step by step process was
created by a team of experts in law and
technology,
law and technology playing zoom.
Legal Zoom is not a law firm,
but can connect you with the third party
attorney and provide you with self help
services for wills to business formations,
trademarks, powers of attorneys,
and more. Go to legal zoom.com
for even more savings.
Type in burb Bu Rr into the
referral box at checkout.
Don't put off the the
things you need to do.
Go to legal zoom.com now and use the
discount code bur bur that's legalzoom.com
discount code birth. All right, there you
go. That was pretty painless this week.
Um, anyways. Okay,
so I watched the Golden Globes
and watch most of them last night.
Um, as you do, you know,
I was watching all the football this
weekend, so I figured, you know,
I got to come her way. I'll sit down. Oh
cool. We'll come and watch it with me.
I worry.
I want you to watch it with me.
So I sat down and I watched
the Golden Globes and
what wasn't working. It wasn't bad
for an award show. It wasn't bad.
The hosts were great.
They were funny. And uh,
the only thing that bugged me was the
amount of people who went up there and
when they won a golden globe, like, all
right, God, I can't, I have that tablet.
I was not ready for it as ready
for you a fucking nominated
Jesus Christ head.
You fucking bets the amount of people
that went up there and said, oh my God,
I can't believe this. I, I'm not prepared.
I didn't think I was going to fucking win.
You know,
like some fucking backup
goalie just sitting there and
all of a sudden, you know,
they are not getting in this game. We're
up five. Nothing is a joke. You know,
you start texting on the bench and all
of a sudden the start and goalie pulls
his groin and now you got to go out there.
What the fuck?
Yeah,
unbelievable. Do you see? How might
you want to see how it's done?
You should have seen Michael Douglas
the way he accepted his golden globe.
First of all,
for some fucking reason.
Anybody who won a golden globe last night
was seated like 75 yards away and you
had to fucking walk all the way down
and then backstage and then come walking
out from backstage. Like everybody didn't
just see you get up from your table.
So what does he do?
He assesses the situation like Jesus
Christ has taken too fucking long.
So the second he gets called, he doesn't
go, all right, God, all right, got it.
Do you believe it?
And you know,
clasp his hands together and then slam
him down into his lap. You know the Hacky,
I've just won an award in
show business move. He didn't,
he got up and he starts jogging,
right?
Like a wily veteran, a grizzled veteran
who's knows how to utilize the clock.
He's running up to the offensive line.
He fucking gets on the stage. He,
he goes into a great story about how he
got the part he thanked everybody before
the fucking oboe player
even started was phenomenal.
It's like watching Joe Montana,
Joe Montana run a two minute offense.
It was great. He did everything but
say John Candy in the crowd. Right?
That's probably a bad joke because
he could have been at a crowd.
He would have been at a crowd if
he didn't die shit. You know what?
It was a great analogy right up until
then, but other than that, I swear to God,
like 40% of the people went
up there and said, oh my God,
I can't fucking believe it. What do
you mean? Can't fucking believe it?
What do you mean you're not prepared?
Didn't the fact that you got
nominated months ago or weeks ago,
it's like a fucking 50 seconds.
They give you like a minute.
You know who you're
supposed to. Thank right.
Is that just like what
you're supposed to do?
He's supposed to have false
humility. False humility. So he said,
if I ever win a golden globe,
I'm not going to be fucking modest at all.
I'll just be up there talking shit.
Okay,
well before I even get up to the
podium. That's right. That's right.
I'm not going to come up here
and pretend to be modest. Dude,
I fucking crushed it this year.
Do you see what I was working?
You see that horse shit that they put
on the paper that I'd bring the life,
pay attention to me, Alice. That was
supposed to be me yelling at Ambi Davis,
Jesus Christ. I this, I don't what
the Fuck I had to keep walking out.
There was some Zombie that went up there.
First of all,
she sat for fucking a minute looking
around just milking the whole fucking
moment, you know? And she was
a classic old actress, right?
She had the body of a 23 year old
and and the in the face of a mummy,
you know, go fuck yourself if you
think that's to mean all right.
Dress and act of God damn.
Age with the fucking shoe Polish in your
hair coming down there looking like a
sexy scarecrow. Anyways,
so she fucking comes down.
They like something out of a horror movie.
I literally,
I had to walk out of the room. I have
this thing, not only do I hate bombing,
I can't stand watching people bomb I,
it makes me uncomfortable.
I had to walk out.
Nia sat there with their hand up to her
mouth and I don't know what this woman
was doing.
At one point I heard she asked another
actor to stand up in the crowd for
inspiration. I'm sure everybody's ripping
her apart on the fucking Internet,
but Jesus Christ just
go up and say thank you.
Okay,
I'm site.
This is great.
I'm gonna make way more money
now because I have one of these
women who are completely out of my league.
Might actually do a little double
take when I walked down the street.
Thank you so much.
I'm going to hold this thing under my
Chin like I'm telling a ghost story.
So the gold is reflected off my face.
Thank you everybody right
in the shit that I said.
Thank you for editing and thankfully
make me look good. I go fuck yourself.
What's up to the band and you're out.
How fucking difficult is that?
I'm not saying you won't be nervous.
I don't fucking know a guy. I
can't believe it. I can't believe
you know like you will.
I had a fucking Chinese restaurant,
a bunch of balloons came down from
the ceiling. Okay. I just had no idea.
Really.
You just walk around dressed like that.
You didn't notice the other
celebrities in the room?
Yeah.
Why do you have to pretend
you're not fucking site?
Yeah.
Anyways.
Um,
that's why I love when Cuba Gooding them,
won the Oscar and he started running
around like some fucking soccer mom that
just want to know when a new or whatever
the fuck they drive was minivans or the
publisher's clearing house
just showed up at his house.
That's what the fuck you should do.
Right.
Map gives a fuck. Anyways. You,
you watch how I handle it at the,
at the awards.
Did they, I think they have those
have those when it's time to change.
Um,
they actually have podcasting awards.
They should have you accept
him like fucking a over Skype.
You know, you shouldn't be in
a, in the flesh. Should you?
Shouldn't we just be voices? Um,
all right, let's plow ahead here.
Okay.
Golden Globes. What did I want
to talk about here? Oh yeah.
I started doing yoga this year.
I'm thinking of a nice long pause here
as I wait for every guy who's listening
to this to say a couple
of homophobic things.
MMM.
And I bought these great stretchy pants
that I wear and a half shirt, you know,
cause you really want to be like,
don't judge me,
but you really just want to like,
you don't want to feel like
mmm.
You don't have like loose clothing on,
you know,
you want to feel like you're being held.
Sorry,
I'm just trying to put a disgusting image
in your head of me with yoga pants and
a half shirt. Yeah. Think
about that. You know
my pasty white belly
muffin top hanging over.
All right. So of course I can't just
do a little bit of Yoga and get my,
you know,
stretch out my fucking spine after
all these hours I spent on airplanes.
My fucking,
you know,
all in nothing stupid
attitude in life is I go from,
I'm going to start doing yoga again this
year cause I haven't done it like three
fucking years.
MMM.
I immediately just go from,
I'm going to start doing yoga too.
I'm going to do 150
hours of yoga this year,
which translates to three hours a year,
which translates to me also going what
about years a week from them on the road
and I one of a chance to,
I need to build up extra time
so I can stay ahead of it.
You know like one of those Scifi movies
where you need that energy life force on
your fucking bracelet.
Right?
I'm trying to get extra extra guys like
you'd, you're playing like a video game.
So of course I go too far and I fucking,
I think I slightly hyper
extended my God damn knee.
What an asshole. I do this all the
time. If I'm gonna start playing drums,
I played drums too much in a part
in my fucking shoulder on my hand.
I don't know.
I don't want my fucking problem is,
I think that's why I succeeded as a
comedian because there's no way to like
physically hurt yourself as a standup
comic. You just standing there talking,
right?
I guess you could ask something out so
much that you accidentally throw yourself
off the stage, but you could still
come up and do it the next show, right?
I Dunno. Anyways, so yeah,
I'm too old to lift.
I'll lift a little bit,
but what happens is you just still eating
light shit. Then you just get that.
I'm still lifting middle aged
body. We were, we have a shirt on.
You can kind of see that the
shoulders in this pex there,
but like you belly still sticking out.
All right.
You know those guys and then they
always have some sort of wallet chain.
I don't want to be that guy. I really
don't want to be that guy. So anyways,
we'll see.
We'll see what happens.
Yeah.
Oh, why do I always
fucking do that? You know,
some fucking day one I'm going to do yoga
and with within three days I'm trying
to do like a fucking full split
and then I get hurt and then I'm just,
you know what happened?
I smoked a cigar or less than I
got to stop with this fucking shit.
You know what?
At my age.
What's really scary is I lose a drinking
buddy every week at my age at 45 they
just dropping like flies. The
wife says, I have to cut down.
I got a fatty liver. I got a kid.
I can't fucking do it anymore.
Okay.
All right. All right. I'm gay and that's
why I was drinking all these years.
All of those fucking things.
You know,
this is like nobody left.
Two of my buddies,
I lost two guys this week
telling me I got to stop.
There's something wrong with my
stomach and I got a fatty liver
and all I'm thinking is this, how
come I'm not feeling anything? Well,
probably because I never got
my liver checked out. You
don't feel anything right?
He just walked down the street one day.
Okay
with your fucking a wallflower knows man,
my little chicken eat right and then all
of a sudden you just do a face plant.
It's over.
Is that how you die of cirrhosis?
Cyrus is cirrhosis. Scorsese.
I don't fucking know. Um,
okay.
Yeah, I got to lay off. I'm
done with fucking cigars.
I'm done with those things,
man. Those things are, and it's
like sucking on a bus tailpipe.
It just [inaudible] inhale a great,
so I just get fucking mouth and
throat cancer. What am I an asshole?
I got to stop this shit.
It's the hardest thing about being an
adult is you have to be your own fucking
parent.
Yeah.
You know,
when you were a kid,
you know your parents were there to
stop you from eating a whole sleeve of
cookies. You, you will.
The second you move up,
you can do whatever the fuck you want.
You can literally be doing heroin, Azure,
written fucking cookies. And
there's nobody there to say, stop.
Okay,
fucking annoying.
I gotta lay off of it.
I can't do it though. I can. I just
can't seem to get, you know what it is?
It's all these social things.
Football game's coming up,
going to a hockey game that
starts tomorrow, starts
tomorrow, and then last night,
you know, Joey Rose's got me a
great fucking bottle of this stuff.
Fucking, I don't Japanese
Scotch. And I'm like, well,
I got to try it.
And of course it was absolutely delicious.
Now I've got to have a
fucking cigar with it.
I'm sitting out on my porch
with my red sox robot.
My bathrobe is also my smoking jacket.
Um,
cause I'm an environmentalist and
I'm sitting out there smoking.
There's nothing dumber than smoking
a really good cigar when you're cold.
It's another thing too.
This is a bad time of year to smoke a
cigar cause you can't smoke anywhere
inside.
They smell like shit unless you're in a
cigar bar and then you're in there with
like 50 other guys in
this, in, in, you know,
it just feels like you're in a walk in
closet with a car on after a while your
eyes are burning.
I can't even do it.
You know what it reminds me of is back
in the day when people could smoke in
comedy clubs and um,
it was unreal. By the
time you got to, it's,
you've got to do three shows
or even two shows back then.
Cause everybody had seemed
smoked back then they would,
there'd be like a cloud of smoke,
you know,
by.
But at the beginning of the second show
because it was still left over from the
first show.
And I just remember like my eyes would
be burning when I got off stage and the
second show I'd have to go to the bathroom
and like flush him out with water and
then I go home
and I actually learned,
uh,
to take a shower the night before you
went to bed because I always remember the
next morning I would wake up and I take
a shower in the water came over my head.
I would just smell the smoke like
someone was smoking next to me.
So I imagine even that,
how bad smoking is,
I can even imagine that being around a
bunch of people who were smoking and then
laying in bed with this smoke in your
clothes and in your hair is somehow
affecting your health. It's just
bad. I am giving away my cigars. I'm,
I'm fucking, I can't say I'm
done, done with them, but I'm,
I'm pretty much done with them.
What I'm going to do is when I go to
other countries, I'll smoke a Cuban cigar.
That's what I'll do. And
then I'm not bringing a bunch
back because then he'd go,
oh fuck, I got to smoke these,
these are Cubans. I don't
want them to go bad. Right?
And then you don't have a humor door cause
you don't want to get sucked into the
habit. And then what happens is
you fucking cigars are going bad.
It's a nightmare.
Um,
I'm going to get a bunch of texts
first world problem. No, it hasn't.
Cuban cigars are made in a third
world country, so go fuck yourself.
Isn't that,
is that considered a third world country?
What is exactly a third world country?
A country that were oppressing?
Is that what makes them Third World?
Okay.
It isn't just South America,
isn't it? Oh Christ.
Now I gotta look it up and there's a
bunch of people laughing at me right now.
But if I actually asked you to give
me a fucking intelligent definition,
you couldn't.
Third World countries.
Yeah.
Wait,
third world definition.
Let's go with that first dude
to do two to two to third world.
Okay? According to Wikipedia, term,
third world arose during the Cold War
to define countries that remained non
aligned with either NATO,
with the United States or western Europe,
western European nations and their allies
representing the first world or the
communist bloc. And that would
be what? The Soviet Union,
the People's Republic of China. Oh, Cuba.
So Cuba is not third world cause they
aligned themselves with the Soviet Union
and their allies representing
the Second World War.
Yeah.
So I'm guessing that we came up with it
because we're the first, first world.
We're number one.
All the commies are ranked number
two and then a distant third.
You know the key. Oh, so based Mexico,
according to this chart,
fall of Central America all
the way down to South America.
Except there's one in South America
that isn't.
What the fuck is that? I don't know
what that is, is just north of Brazil.
Oh, does that Burns and Allen, what's the
name of that fucking country down there?
Cakes and biscuits. I don't
know. Fucking it up. Um,
let's let you know and I think it's time
mercifully for the questions this week.
What do you say everybody,
what do you say? You Ready?
You ready for the questions for this week?
I, God knows I am. Oh, really? Quickly.
I didn't even get a
chance to talk about it.
Do you guys do watch that 60 minutes
thing last night of that fucking jerk off?
He's ratting out Alex Rodriguez,
the Henry Hill of that think.
All right.
I'm pulling up Paul Versey, the
dude I call it, I called it.
We're all going to be on
Roids by the end of our lives.
Okay.
And I'm going to tell you why.
Because the same reason why you
saw that sexy scare squirrels,
scarecrow walking into the fucking stage.
The same reason why they got all these
diet pills and all this fucking grow your
hair back shit. Because no one
wants to be old and decrepit.
Okay?
All right.
They're already given the shit out.
That's synergetics is fucking
HGH as far as I can tell.
Okay.
Um,
which is basically I researched,
I said synergetics uh,
scandal.
That's what I searched. So of course
negative shit came up about them. Um,
we're all going to be on it.
It's the same way w marijuana
is gradually becoming legal.
That's what's going to happen with,
with, with steroids. Guaran fucking tee.
You know what's the coolest part of the
story was they said a rod texted this
Guy Tony, whatever the fuck his name
was, and Joe [inaudible]. He said, hey,
I got a big day tomorrow. What do
you got? So we gave him the stuff.
The next day you would
have like two doubles and a
single or something like that
and the 60 minute guy goes,
Ooh,
what did you think after you sent him
your products and saw the results?
And he was going like,
he basically said
that, yeah, we, we got the formula down.
You held the formula down and
he goes, yeah. It was like,
it was like shooting fish in a barrel.
So these guys are so
advanced in this illegal shit
that I'm telling you, they're going to
get it to the point where it just like we,
where you can smoke it through like
a breathalyzer. We're all it is,
is just basically the mist of THC.
Whatever the fuck that
stuff is that gets you high,
they're going to get that with what?
Steroids.
Okay.
All right.
And you're going to be 80
years old walking around
feeling like you can put your
fucking fist through the Goddamn wall.
Okay.
It's going to be great.
All right. And all of this,
this witch hunt on these a rod guys and
all these guys went to jail and all that
type of shit that people are going
to look back and be like, well,
what was the problem?
That's, that's my prediction.
Yeah.
Provided an asteroid doesn't hit
his first. Um, oh, by the way,
I retweeted something that
somebody sent me about, uh,
the Denver International Airport.
You know,
that there's basically a, that they
started to build it and then they said,
well, the structure is
wrong. And then they,
rather than destroying what they built,
they buried it.
And then they built the
airport on top of it.
So all the conspiracy
theorists just saying this is
a bunker for all the fucking
people who are going to just survive a
nuclear holocaust or an economic meltdown.
And there are a bunch of weird
paintings on the, on the walls.
But if you really look at them
objectively, it kind of looks more,
it's more about world peace,
oppression.
And then the children of the next
generation coming along and oppressing the
oppressors are stomping them out. And
then there's no war, no more weapons.
You can look at it in a sunshiny way
or you can look at it in a creepy way.
And I got to admit a lot of the, the
at work is a pretty creepy. I was,
I'll send you guys a link to
that shit. But it's a pretty
interesting, uh, I don't,
I love conspiracy theory because I know,
you know,
I know how much I lie.
So why would they be so I love the
speculation. All right, here we go. Let's,
let me shut the fucking get on with the,
uh, the questions for the week. All right.
This one says ponies dot, dot,
dot. I'm a retard t. Why builtin?
Yeah, I'm a colts fan. Um, I guess that's
a reference to some guy who plays on the,
uh, on the fucking cults. I don't know.
I don't know anybody's name anymore.
I don't know who shot. I
don't really do that. He goes,
I'm listening to the eight 26,
13 podcasts where you talk about the
difference between a pony and a horse. Oh,
it was making fun of the fact that I,
I,
for until I was like in my early twenties,
I didn't realize that a pony is
a pony in a horse is a horse.
I thought a pony was a small horse and
the people down the street had a pony.
My whole childhood tied to the back of
their fucking house. It's kind of cruel.
But, uh, I remember driving by and
finally when I was like 19, 20 years old,
my mother was driving and I was just like,
what does that pony going
to turn into a horse? And,
and if I could just go back and listen
to the October 26 podcast the last year,
I explain it way better.
The fucking look my mother gave me
before she started laughing at me. Um,
I still see it on her face every time when
I come home for Thanksgiving. Anyways,
I'm 23 years old.
He said 23 year old American
English was my first language.
I have my bachelor's degree.
I am going to law school in August.
I scored higher on the
law school admission test,
the 97 [inaudible] 97%
of potential lawyers.
And I just had to look on Wikipedia to
find out that ponies are indeed not young
horses. I am ashamed of
myself. Go Fuck Yourself.
At least I can read out loud. Hey, yeah,
the chalk you look at least
you can read out loud, dude,
you did all that other stuff.
I can't do that.
You've got to take me out because you're
all so fucking stupid. Anyways, he goes,
thanks for the free labs. Your
Colorado Springs show was amazing. Uh,
go Andrew Luck. Well, he's going
to the golf course there, buddy.
Um, yeah, for all you people out there,
pony is a pony and a horse is a horse.
I guess I was a small horses. A
cult. Is that what you'd call it?
You know what's amazing is that I don't
know what it is and I never take the
time to look it up. So I always sound
dumb in this conversation. Okay.
Advice on men. Hey,
bumbling. Billy Bul. Uh,
I'll keep the questions short to rescue
you from the English language, but up, up,
up, up, when I get it, I
suck at reading out loud.
He goes, I'm a 20. Oh, she says,
oh my God, this is from a Olay.
Uh, I finally get a female
to write in and I trashed,
you're right out of the gate.
I'm sorry sweetheart. She says,
I'm a 24 year old girl and I'd like
to know your best piece of advice of
understanding the human male species.
Many thanks. But at the same time,
go fuck yourself while I'm sorry.
You gotta be a little more specific.
Um, I'll give you a,
basically, generally speaking,
um, oh, Jesus Christ.
What do you want to know? I
would basically, you know,
you want to learn how to
communicate with them better. Um,
yeah, so you're doing the right
thing. You're asking another part.
This is actually a very smart question.
Rather than sitting around with your
female friends just going, I know, right?
What if,
what if that God,
yeah.
You sit there to fucking wine bar whining.
This what you do.
You go cross enemy lines and yes,
you know, a trader like me to
read from the playbook. All right,
how guys communicate.
I can't say that.
We just say what we're thinking because
we have liars and passive aggressive
people and a meandering little man boys.
But generally speaking, uh, the
thing that confuses us the most,
I did a bit, I can't remember
if I did it on a special, but
yeah.
One time I was driving
with Nia and I said,
hey, I want to get a chocolate
shake. We're going by this diner,
and she freaks out. She's like, oh my
God, they make the best chocolate shakes.
And I go, I know, right? She
goes, yeah. She just goes,
oh my God, that, that, that,
that they're so big.
She just kept saying this so big.
After a while I'm thinking
like, yeah, like fuck,
how the fuck am I going
to drink this whole thing?
And then immediately just clicked on me.
Like it's like they're not big
this standard size. Wait a minute,
she wants half of my shake,
but she doesn't want to seem selfish,
but she doesn't want all the
calories of the full shake Sarah.
But she doesn't want to look like
she's taken away 50% of my good time.
So rather than telling me that she's
trying to mind fuck mean to thinking
something that I drank a zillion
times with ease is now too big.
You know what I mean?
So that's how you guys communicate.
Okay.
I don't know how we communicate because
I can't just sit there and make it seem
like guys were heroes and that
where they would be like, listen,
I'm trying to lose weight, so,
uh, can I have half your shake?
MMM.
The only thing I can tell you
is you're 24 years old. Uh, it,
you shouldn't understand them.
You shouldn't understand guys,
but it's hard for me to,
I don't know what you're asking.
Please write back. Please write back
advice on men park to just do that again.
Just fucking write back asked me something
more specific and I can help you out.
But it's great that a 24 year actually
smart enough to ask guys to explain.
Um, ah, let's see. Best piece of
advice. I use a great piece of advice.
Learn how to cook.
All right?
It's stereotypical is that fucking sounds,
I don't mean it in the,
as this in a sexist fucking way.
All right.
I don't,
don't be a slob and learn how to cook
would put you ahead of 80% of fucking
women out there because for some reason,
somewhere along Edith Wharton over that
chicken showed the flag making a guy his
sandwich became this absolutely
degrading fucking thing to do.
Yet guys still have to hold the doors and,
and fucking buy drinks.
Like why we don't find that sexist,
reverse sexist or whatever
the fuck you call it.
I remember one time I was downstairs,
don't know what the fuck I was doing.
I was doing some pain in the ass job.
I was cleaning out something
in the garage and without,
yeah,
me asking or anything.
Nia came downstairs with
this unbelievable sandwich.
She had made pickles toothpick in it.
The whole fucking nine yards.
Yeah.
And she brought like a something
to drink downstairs too.
And I stopped working. I sat down, ate.
It was one of the greatest
moments of our relationship.
All right, so that's some advice I
would give you is guys have a very,
we're very simple and by simple,
I don't mean stupid before you
get on your fucking high horse,
okay?
It's like an old school engine. You open
the hood and everything's right there.
Real wheel drive. It's not turned to
the side jammed into the compartment.
None of that bullshit.
It's just fucking basic.
You just do that every
once in a fucking while.
Guys will think I have a keeper and
all you're doing is making a fucking
sandwich. And that doesn't mean that
you shouldn't have the right to vote.
It's fucking unreal. Cook it. And
then you don't even cook and all,
you know when he's just
slapping shit together,
you build in a little fucking food house.
How difficult is that?
Okay,
that's what I don't understand. Like I
guess I kind of understand it, but like
cooking a meal for somebody is one of
the greatest things you could ever do for
them. All right, I'll leave it at that.
So I would say something simple like that.
This is how simple guys are.
If you actually, every once
in a while just said, hey,
do you want to bear?
And you actually got up and went to the
fridge and got a beer and brought it
over, put it in a fucking
frosted mug. I mean,
personally speaking,
I'm ready to go paint the house
cause that little move there,
I feel like a fucking king.
That's all it takes.
Very simple.
Okay.
You know, let them head out
with his friends once a week.
If they come over and they watched the
game and you're not into the game, leave.
Okay,
go in the other room or
be a good shit and hang,
but don't ruin as good fucking
time. Jesus, I'm on a roll here now
is another one.
Uh, try to limit the amount of horrific
shit you're going to drag him to.
Now he's,
he's obligated to goes to some of it,
but he has to have just set
it up and just say, listen,
there's a bunch of shit that you do
that I'm not going to begin to write.
Like tailgating on a golf course
peeing in a Porta potty before,
before a football game that
you don't give a shit about.
I don't want to be there for that. So
I get to tap out of that. All right.
And then the guy he gets to
tap out of like, I dunno,
like what have I tapped out on one time
a Nia wanted to take me to somebody's
birthday party. They were
having some fucking, you know,
we're all gonna dress like it's the gold
rush or the fucking prohibition era.
It's like,
I don't want to fucking do that.
She gave me shit and I was just
saying I don't want to do it.
And she let me out of it
and we laughed about it.
I actually went there without a costume.
I mean I made a deal. We made it,
we made a, we made a deal. I think I told
this story, I'm fucking punch drunk. Yeah.
I never know what the
fuck I'm talking about.
I showed up and I didn't wear a costume,
which was hilarious cause every other guy
was fucking dress like Charlie Chaplin.
And I show up in street clothes and
they're looking at me like I'm a magician.
And then I left early cause that's right.
Cause I would have watched the Celtics
were playing the Lakers in the finals
that year when we beat him.
And I would have missed it if nia
wasn't so fucking cool. So that's,
that's what I would do.
And if you actually do shit like that,
you know,
you put yourself on this solid
ground with the guy that you're with,
we're now,
there's no reason for him to be an
asshole to you or be mean to you because
you've been so nice to him.
It really kind of works that way.
It kind of feeds off each other.
That's the best I can do
without a specific question.
All right, so there you go.
And you know, fuck everybody.
Who's going to say that?
You know what I just said was
sexist. You know, go fuck yourself.
I don't think it's,
you know,
you're on a date with your woman.
You go and you open the car door for you
still do that shit. If I can do that,
he can go get me a fucking
beer. Christ. It's a twist off.
What are you gonna hurt your wrist?
Yeah.
You know something that that would be
my advice. Stop acting like a kicker.
You know what?
We're just fucking annoys me.
That every time a kicker makes a
tackle, he gets hurt. I just fucking,
I just don't understand
that Jesus fucking Christ.
Put some cream on it and get back out
there and fucking throw your feet around.
All right. College
Room. Uh, Billy Vanilli.
I liked that one as a new one. Uh,
can't wait to see you in Hamilton,
Ontario. I'm a 21 year old college
student who, oh, by the way, I'm,
I'm hopefully going to have the,
uh,
the links to those dates
in the next week or so.
Everybody asks you about all the,
my,
my big Canadian tour in much anyways,
this person says,
can't wait to see you in Hamilton,
Ontario.
I'm a 21 year old college student who
has been having to deal with rumors.
Um, I was a resident on
dawn a couple months back,
which means I was responsible for
watching over first year students in their
dorms during Halloween.
I did hook up with one of
the first years at a party.
I was at word somehow spread,
but through classic broken telephone
that I got a drunk and banged her in the
elevator of her dorm,
uh,
consistently when I am at any,
I think you meant to say consequently,
what am at any social gathering party?
Kegger when I tell a girl my name,
they immediately walk away as
if I'm some monster. Oh No.
I'm thinking of transferring school
as a fair share of the campus.
Thinks I'm that creepy guy around girls.
Any advice on addressing this room are
with girls to stop them from running for
the hills would be greatly appreciated.
Um,
I don't know. Dude. Did you
do it if you didn't do it?
I don't know. If you didn't
do it, I would talk to the,
to the woman that you hooked
up with. Can you say, listen,
can you please tell people that I didn't
get your drunk, that that didn't happen?
Um, I don't, I don't know.
Well, I mean I don't,
I don't know if people are mature
enough once it gets out like that.
Maybe she's embarrassed that
she hooked up with an older guy.
I have no fucking idea.
MMM.
I Dunno.
I don't like those creepy sex ones
because now I'm going to have to do this.
I have to assume that you are innocent.
Yeah.
Who would get a somewhat look,
I gotta tell you this.
Who would get somebody drunk and then
fuck them in a public place like that.
If you're doing something under handled,
like that story doesn't even make
sense unless you wanted to get caught.
Okay.
Ah,
whatever.
Okay.
I don't, I, you know, I
don't know how to get you,
it's once you get accused
of sexually weird shit,
you kind of do have to leave I guess.
But then they win.
Yeah.
I don't know. Dude. That sucks. I really
hope that, you know, if you are innocent,
I really hope that uh,
you can somehow get out of that.
Cause that's that fucking thing
where I always felt like, you know,
somebody gets accused of
some sort of sex crime.
Like I don't think that they should
just put their name in the fucking paper
until they're there.
They're convicted.
Yeah.
It's even, and everybody in your
world is gonna know about it.
Yeah.
And, uh, if you didn't do it once,
you're just accused of it. You get done,
you're done. It's fucking over. I don't,
I don't mean not in back of the day.
At least you could, you could go
a couple of states over, you know,
change your name to fucking Tj or some
shit and fucking start a new life.
You can't do it.
Now I have the social media,
the Internet and everything
just follows you around. Um,
okay.
You know what? I was doing it,
I would stop going to parties.
I would get sober and I would just say,
you know,
yeah.
Just and I, I would, I don't
know, stone sober, meet a
nice girl and just say, yeah,
I mean,
I hooked up with this girl
and then somebody started
this fucking rumor and yeah,
okay,
I'm done with it. I don't want to do
this shit anymore. I don't got to,
I don't know how to, I honestly, I don't
know how to get out of that. Jesus,
he's a fucking hard questions this week.
Okay.
I don't, fuck, I don't, I
just, if you transfer, you're
admitting that you're wrong.
Okay.
Well where the fuck are your friends
who can back you up going out of that's
bullshit.
You got nothing.
You just a loner. Yeah.
Jesus. I don't know. Alright.
Motorcycle through Thailand.
Jesus Christ.
If you wrote a motorcycle to Thailand,
you the toughest fucking guy I know.
Unless you're from there.
Uh, dear Billy Budd Baxter.
Yeah.
I'm glad to hear your 2014
it starting off strong.
I remember you talking a few weeks back
about being able to drive all to be able
to drive all things.
I've had that same philosophy for a few
years now and I've been working towards
learning how to do just that.
I'm 25 hours into getting my pilot's
license and in November I took a basic
motorcycle driving course over a weekend.
I think you have taken something similar.
Yeah.
I got a motorcycle license a couple of
weeks after the course with no additional
motorcycle experience and never having
driven outside of a parking lot.
I flew to Thailand,
Jesus Christ there.
I went to the northern mountains and
rented a two 50 cc dual purpose dirt bike
and drove for nine days
around the Mae Hong Son loop.
The fuck is that though.
It can easily be done in five or six days.
Google it if you feel like it.
It was easily the best
experience of my entire life.
I was able to get out of the the shit,
show tourists,
clap trap areas and see what the fuck
was going on in the day to day lives of a
bunch of ties. The food was incredible.
The views were out of this world.
The people are the most
friendly in the world. See,
I have all these stereotypes like
I wouldn't want to go up there,
I think going to get kidnapped or some
shit and I was able to gain some real
chops when it comes to riding a bike.
Plus I got to stop in a couple of small
tourist based towns and met a beautiful
Scandinavian girl.
Oh and it didn't hurt that 50 baht.
I don't know how to say it.
A dollar 50 American,
we'll get you all the foods
you can eat and 400 baht.
We'll get you a beautiful bamboo hut in
the middle of the Goddamn rain forest
for the night. I doubt anyone will give
a shit about your standup in Thailand.
It's not you,
it's them.
But you should definitely make a trip out
there and drive around and on a rented
motorcycle. I got tons
of more information. If
you're actually interested,
thanks for the free labs. Come to
Durham, North Carolina as soon. Uh,
and go fuck yourself. Um, dude,
I would love to do that.
I'm just afraid to go.
There's certain places where you
go, I don't, you get put on a list.
Isn't Thailand the one we're fucking
pervert Goto to bang a little boys.
Okay.
No,
we got enough Thai food over here.
They just assume they don't assume you're
going over there to ride a bike on the
fucking Ho Chi Minh loop or whatever
the fuck he just did over there.
They think you going over there for
that. But that sounds awesome. That is,
that is a bucket list goal of mine.
I do.
I want to be in scenic place in
another country on a motorcycle.
Okay.
That, I mean, why wouldn't
you want to fucking do that?
Ride around and pretend like you're
tough and you know how to fight.
That's just what I want to do.
Um, congratulations. Well, I
never even heard of that for the,
for those few listeners at home,
if you're at your desk right now and you
don't want to fucking do work, do work,
you don't want to be working. Uh, let
me, let me spell that out for you.
A flew to Thailand,
the Mae Hong Son loop,
Mae Hong as in Hong Kong,
h o n g n s o n.
Loop.
Okay.
By the way,
what's up with fucking Dr Evil in
North Korea feed and his uncle to dogs.
Is that true?
Yeah,
I kind of have to believe that because
it's not like they have to sway public
opinion liberal or
Conservative about that guy.
Okay.
At fat jerk off. The fuck is wrong
with you if you're listening to this,
cause I know your dad was a big movie
fan and maybe you want to rebel against
your dad and listen to the podcast.
If you lit listening to this,
uh, dude, you're headed
towards an ugly death.
You're not going to survive doing shit
like that. That's not the way to do it.
I don't know.
Did Your Dad own the godfather trilogy?
And you're trying to act like everybody
in your world is fucking Mo Green.
Maybe you have to do that. You
should have just shot the guy, dude,
if you do stuff like that, like the
level of fear that that put in me,
and I'm not even in your country.
I'm already thinking.
I think my first thought after I got over
the wave of fear of that was I have to
kill this guy. If I lived in the country,
that's what I would have two bullets,
one for him, and then I'd shoot myself
just in case I do. You know what?
I'd shoot the dude.
Okay.
And then I would wait half a second.
And if I didn't hear applause,
I would then shoot myself
because I always felt if you took out a
guy who's just ruling with that level of
psychosis,
okay.
Um,
that if you took them out,
is everybody sitting there
looking down at the floors?
He's saying the next crazy thing he
wanted to do that if you actually took 'em
out that on some level people
boot would be like, uh,
the second you did it would be like, ah,
God, thank God you did it. Jesus Christ.
I thought I was the only one. Um,
all right. I don't fucking know.
Let me,
uh,
let me move on to the last one here and
I got to wrap this podcast up cause I
got a, I'm going to do Joe Barton
next podcast. Today's picking me up.
This is a podcast Monday baby.
All right.
Drunk girlfriend issue a uh,
I'll wait a second. I got,
I got to read the last couple of ads
here real quick, real quick, real quick.
Really quickly.
stamps.com everybody go,
oh Geez.
Is stamps.com one great resolution
you can make for new for the new year.
Maximize every minute and every
dollar for your small business.
I know an easy way to do that with what?
With stamps.com think about how much time
your waste you've wasted going to the
post office driving. They're finding
parking, getting around the homeless guy,
holding the door stamps.com is
the better way to get postage.
Just use what you already have,
your computer and your printer to get
official us postage for any letter or
package. Um, and then you put
it out in the mailbox. Mailman
picks it up, bing, Bang,
boom. You're done with
stamps.com everything you
would do with the post office,
you could do it right there at your own
desk and at a fraction of the cost for
one of those expensive postage meters.
I've been using stamps.com for about
three years. It's so convenient.
Any crap that I'm selling after my shows,
I run it through the little scale thing.
I put a stamp on it and it's at the
place I've never had a problem and I'm a
moron, so if I can use it, you can too.
Right now use my last name bur
bur to get this special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer that
includes a digital scale and F and up
to $55 free postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before
you do anything else,
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com
enter
bur
bur are. If you're not
doing that I, I you just,
you just enjoy life being
difficult. All right, he voice,
you're a business owner but automatic
automated phone systems and secretaries
are not in your budget just yet.
And juggling incoming calls yourself
makes it hard to look like a professional.
Basically you biting off more
than than you could chew.
Here's something that will
dramatically help you make more money.
In 2014 he voice whether you're a business
of one or 100 eve voice will help you
manage all of your incoming calls
with a toll free number. Dial by name,
directory and call routing tools.
Your business will sound like 1 million
bucks tank. Can't take a call he voice.
We'll transcribe the
voicemail and email it to you.
Never be caught off guard again and with
he voice you can try it before you buy
it right now.
Just from my listeners,
you can get a 60 day
free trial to eve voice.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and enter
the Promo code bill at checkout.
Take charge of your Jesus Bill.
Come on,
take charge of your business and make
more money in 2014 go to [inaudible] dot
com and enter bill at checkout
for your 60 day free trial.
That's [inaudible] dot com
promo code bill B. I. L. L.
Good Lord people can you
beat that 60 day free trial?
You just starting your business right
out of the gate. You sound like a pro.
I wish I had a business idea.
Okay. Drunk girlfriend issue.
This is the last one on the, on the
podcast. Hey Billy Bob Burton. Um,
I'm a big fan of yours,
fellow Bostonian suburb guy as
well and I love the podcast.
I have some relationship issues that I'd
like your input on if you would be so
kind.
You fuck
all. All right. I've been dating my
girlfriend for over four years. I am 26,
she's 25.
We moved in together in September,
2013 because I thought
things were going well.
Well we have some issues and I'm not
sure what to do besides the usual fights
over things where I think logically and
present my side of the argument well
with facts that are
relative to the subject.
And she rambles about how I'm a
mama's boy and have a small Dick. Um,
well yeah, I guess in other
words you're probably right.
So she's just capitulated in
and I was just insulting you.
Granted this is your version of it.
Anyways,
he said my biggest issue is her drinking.
More specifically how she
acts when she's drunk.
When we are drinking in public set
sitting,
that's setting sitting with
the large group of people,
she drinks too much and always blacks out.
This is typically not a normal thing.
It only happens once every few months,
but over the holiday season it happens
every weekend while at company Christmas
parties, hers and mind friend's
houses and while on a pub crawl,
I have two big issues with
her blacking out like that.
One is that it's usually she only
drinks excessively when other people,
mainly her bitchy best friend insists
that my girlfriend should drink a lot.
Even though my girlfriend has a
very low tolerance for alcohol.
It's to the point that her best
friend will say things to her like,
if you don't take this shot,
I hate you slash you're
not my friend Jesus Christ,
and she's being serious.
I spoken with my girl repeatedly about
how I feel that that's not a good idea or
right to allow a friend to do that to
her and my girlfriend replies that she's
not going to say no to her best
friend no matter what Jesus Christ.
This is like a textbook
codependent relationship here. Um,
my second issue is that when she
blacks out, once I get her in the cat,
the car or cab to take her home,
she gets really quiet and starts saying
she hates our relationship. She hates me,
she hates living with me.
She wishes we would break up among other
similar things once she sleeps it off
and wakes up, hung, hung over.
She has no recollection of what
she said to me the night prior.
And she says that drunk
words, they're drunk words and
they mean nothing. Ah, God,
I do not think that way.
They legitimately hurts my feeling and
has feelings and has happened so often
recently that I've been
weighing my options about
whether it's time to end this
relationship and move on.
I'm not sure.
I'm just being a pushy
and need to get over it,
or if I have legitimate gripe here, dude,
you totally have a legitimate gripe.
He says, I care about my girlfriend
a lot. And until recently,
I was beginning to think about proposing
marriage to her at some point. Dude,
you cannot on any fucking level proposed
to this girl with this shit on the
table right now.
He said,
I had planted in my head that if we were
going to live together for two years,
then we had the right stuff for marriage.
Uh, with all this drinking stuff though,
I'm not sure where to go.
If you have any tips or advice,
I'd greatly appreciate it.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Can't wait to see a new special in 2014
hope you perform at Boston. All right?
Yeah, Dude. Um, first things first,
do not on any level proposed
marriage to this woman at all,
on any fucking level.
Um,
what you have to do is you got
to put your foot down. All right?
You have to say both
things that you brought up,
provided you're being honest
with me. Uh, you are 100% in the,
and you have to just say, look, um,
you can't drink like that anymore and
you can't have a relationship with your
friend like that anymore. Um, actually
you can because you are a free individual.
But if you're going to be,
then I want out of this relationship,
I'm not going to be with somebody who
drinks like that and more specifically
drinks like that because her
friend is making a drink like that.
And second of all, you know, I don't, I,
I don't, you know, there's an expression
out there that, what does it say? Uh,
a drunk man's words are
a sober man's thoughts.
I Dunno. I would, oh shit. This
is Bart. Nick, hold on one sec.
Hang on. Hang on Joey beat.
Just wrap it up the podcast.
They'll be outside and two
minutes. Okay. All right. See you.
Um, yeah, so I would basically, uh,
okay, so let's just
compartmentalize this thing. Okay.
If that first issue, just the drinking
thing, I would just lay down the gauntlet.
You if you,
if you want to be with me and you know
I'm not going to be in a relationship
with that going on,
that's unacceptable.
I respect the fact if you still want to
do it, but if you still want to do it,
then you're moving out around,
moving out and we're not going to be a
couple anymore because I'm not tolerating
that.
And you're well within your rights to
do that and it's a great thing to say at
26 years of old to get some sort of self
esteem within a relationship and have
some ground rules with yourself.
This is your half of the circle.
What do I want and what am I willing
to put up with? Where is my line?
You found your line and you tell
her that that's where it is.
You don't have to be a jerk. You
don't have to get angry. Just say,
this is my line and I totally respect
if you want to live on the other side of
the line, I'm just not going to
live with you doing that. Um,
this other shit where she gets,
she says she hates to relationship
and wishes that you broke up. Um,
if it happened one time, whatever.
She does that every fucking time.
I think those are our honest words
and I honestly would consider, see,
consider getting the fuck
out of that relationship. Um,
I think you, you guys have both been
in relationships for a long time.
You got into it when you
were really young. Maybe she
still wants to see, explore,
see what the fucks out there. I
have no idea what that is. A major,
major fucking red flag.
Um,
and uh,
I don't buy it and I also don't buy that
she's 100% drinking like that because
her friend is making her it. Uh, I
think she wants to drink life. She's,
maybe she's drinking like that cause
she's not happy in a relationship.
I don't know. There's a bunch of major
red flags and you 100% the right.
You're not being a pussy,
you're being fucking mature and you're,
you're saying what you want.
Fuck this dude.
You don't want some drunk with some drunk
fucking friend who then gets hammered
and says they don't want to be with you.
When you dream at Lazette your dream girl,
when you sit there and fantasy
kicked this bitch to the curb,
I've added with her.
I'm not even in the fucking relationship.
You could do better. All right?
I'm not saying she's not the one,
but she needs to grow the fuck up.
Don't say it like that, but that,
that's what I believe. And that's, that's
my thoughts and I'm sticking with it.
All right. My buddies, outside of
being a cunt, I gotta get off here. Uh,
have a great week. Go
fuck yourselves. And, um,
that's it. I'll talk to you next week. I'm
looking forward to some great football.
All right.
See you.